when you look at roger penrose for
example is another fascinating figure uh
you know it's possible and i forgive me
if
i'm showing my ignorance but he's also
did some work on
consciousness he's been one of the only
people who spoke about consciousness
which for a longest time and is still
arguably
outside of the realm of the sciences
right
it's still seen as a taboo subject
and and he was brave enough to explore
it
uh from a physics perspective from a
just a philosophical perspective but
like with the rigor
like proposing different kind of
hypotheses of how
consciousness might be able to emerge in
the brain and it's possible that that is
the thing he's remembered for if you
look hundred years from now
right as as opposed to the the work in
the black holes which
fits into the kind of uh asp
like the fits into what the current
scientific
community uh allows to be
the the space of what is and isn't
science yeah it's really interesting to
look at people that are innovators
where in some phases of their career
their ideas fit into the
social structure that is around them but
in other phases
it doesn't and when you look at them
they just operated the same way
throughout
and it's it says more about their
environment than about them
well yeah i i don't know if you know who
max tag mark is yeah just recently
talked to him
i just recently talked to him again and
he uh i mean he was a little bit more
explicit about
saying you know being aware which is
something i also recommend it's like
being aware where the scientific
community stands
and doing enough to get like move along
into your career
in your career and yeah it's the
necessary evil i suppose
if if you are one of those out of the
box thinkers that just naturally have
this childlike curiosity which max
definitely is one of them
is sometimes you have to do some stuff
that fits in you publish and you get
tenure and all those
things but the tenure is a great
privilege because it allows you
to in principle explore things that are
not accepted by
others and unfortunately it's not being
being taken advantage of by most people
and
it's a waste of a very precious resource
you